Mélenchon veut tout faire pour nous
obliger à être soit d'un côté soit de
l'autre et ça n'est pas le sujet on te
parle
d'humanité excuse-moic mond sait que je
ne suis pas une pro Mélenchon et je vais
encore une fois repréciser mon propos il
a fait une grave erreur de dire que ce
n'est pas
r les action par s passé
avant Revan c'est le premier qui a dit
les gars
juste Palestine a droit de faire ses
manifestations et tout ça et moi j'ai
dit bien so manifestation mais la
Palestine aussi je crois que tu éta
d'accord avec moi et maintenant au lieu
de choisir son camp de
PE une autreille dans votre raisonnement
c'est ce que vous appelez les
manifestations pour la paix il y a un
mélange de gens qui sont sincèrement
attachés à la cause palestinienne
mélanger à des gens qui portent des
à la gloire des types qui on découpé des
bébés et mélanger à des gens qui vous
disent les massacres en Israël n'ont pas
existé donc c'est mélangé dans
manifestation avec des né avec des
négation vous des
manifestationses de
mer g man c'est parce ques sont choqué
par le nombre impressionnant de gens qui
me
paltine
oucve très bien une manifestation là
autorisé pour le moment
organis F ce weekend pour
soutenir monter par F c'est une pression
très juste ben oui mais je viens de le
dire non mais non mais attendez
laissez-moi finir une phrase je trouve
ça très
bien non mais je trouve ça très bien que
les gens bah non mais j'ai le droit de
par aller non je vais pas dans les
manies je vais pas dans les man
compliqué voilà je trouve ça très bien
que les gens qui sont pro palestinien
manifeste en France ça a été trop inter
on l'a tous dit ici on on l'a tous dit
ici on l'a tous dit ici
la France insoumiseard vient de dire
notre objectif c'est la panique dans la
rue c'est soneet qui vient de sortir
sorte
attendezes dis les
manifest manifestationganis par
France manifil
onv sous les
bombes
dans je vous dire les gens qui
organisent les manifestations ils avent
pas besoin de la France insoumiseise qui
venueffs
bienis qu'on VO la vidéo d'é hier soir
hier sur ces news
regarde mon métier c'est de commenter
mais là je pas non c'est trop dur
bon c'est trop de ça fait depuis le 7
octobre effectivement qu'on est tous
sous cette charge émotionnelle et
imaginez qu'on puisse en arriver à
mettre un bébé vivant dans un four je
comprends votre émotion
Eric al ça c'était hier chez notre ami
Laurence Ferrari vous avez été submergé
par l'émotion éic nolo bah ce qui est
étonnant c'est pas que je cède à
l'émotion et que je pleure c'est ce qui
est étonnant c'est que tout le monde ne
pleure pas je trouve h en France ouais
quand on quand on entend le récit de ces
abominations euh je crois que c'est le
moment de pleurer en tout cas que chacun
réagiss selon sa propre sensibilité mais
c'est certainement pas le le moment des
petits calculs politiques à la Mélenchon
ou à la France insomise voilà ce que je
dis quand on a le cœur au bon endroit le
cerveau au bon endroit on est déjà
solidaire des victimes et quand on parle
de victimes il y a il y a pas eu d'acte
aussi atroce depuis le nazisme en
réalité ces gens-là sont des nazis et
sur ces agissements là vous avez des
gens qui disent est-ce que ce sont
vraiment des terroristes un bébé vivant
dans un four et ventrer une femme
enceinte est-ce que c'est vraiment
terroriste juste monsieur le député il y
a beaucoup de gens aussi j'ai vu sur les
réseaux qui disent que c'est une c'est
une fausse information est-ce que c'est
une vraie information ou pas mais la
barbarie c'est une vraieation j'ai vu
les camignons frigorifiques s'ouvrir
devant moi 14 je les vu j'ai entendu
cette dame me dire de manière totalement
sincère il y a un enfant et une mère qui
ont été brûé vif ensemble j'ai vu
l'odeur insoutenable ce qui est
révoltant dans ce que fait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est que il aurait dû dire
que c'était des crimes contre l'humanité
enfin bon sens c'est quand même pas
compliqué de dire que c'est des crimes
d'une barbarie sans nom et une fois
qu'il a dit ça madame vous avez raison
il aurait pu dire on parle d'histoire on
réfléchit on parle de paix mais il
aurait dû commencer par dire c'est des
crimes d'une barbarie sans nom on a tué
30 français tout le monde s'en fout il y
a neuf otages il y a neuf
fotages non mais non non mais il y a neu
fotages il y a neu fotages vis juste
dire une chose j'ai grandi moi avec à la
télévision les bandeaux de George
malbruno et d'ervé gekier ils sont où
les bandeaux dans notre pays pour
demander la libération des neuf otages
vous parliez de manifestations je
terminerai là moi je suis pour des
manifestations pour la paix est-ce qu'il
y a un drapeau israélien est-ce qu'
parle des otages il y a pas eu une
mention dans les manifestations sur la
libération des notages il y a neuf
Français aujourd'hui qui sont des
compatriotes il y a pas de mention c'est
pas des rassemblements pour la paix des
rassemblements pour la paix on parle des
otages on parle des français morts il y
a des drapeaux israéliens et
palestiniens ça c'est magifque jeis vous
montrer je vais vous montrer une vidéo
c'est la vidéo Vié qui a fait le plus
parler aujourd'hui c'est une publication
en ligne évoquant le le meurtre d'un
bébé qui aurait été brûlé dans un four
et aujourd'hui cette vidéo fait
énormément parlé c'est une influenceuse
enfin une influenceuse une une abrutie
plutôt qui a traité ce sujet avec une
ironie
insoutenable je sais pas si vous avez vu
cette
vidéo regardez non mais c'est une folle
mais c'est une folle mais ça circule sur
les réseaux et ça a été énormément vu
donc les chériis quand on parle des
réseaux un moment un moment il faut
vraiment que me réve comme la vidéo des
jeunes
he Devi nimporo dis et ça ça a
énormément circulé avant d'être enlevé
donc regardez cette vidéo abusé moi il y
a une chose qui me qui me ture le pine
je je je vais je vais je vais vous
donner le fond de ma pensée sans filtre
à chaque fois que je tombe sur
l'histoire du bébé qui a été mis dans le
four je me pose la question de s'ils ont
mis du sel du poivre s'ils ont mis du
thint ils l'ont faire venir à quoi et et
ça a été quoi
l'accompagnementz pas la question sur
vous je sais pas accompagnement avec ce
gigot de bébé n'était qu'autre qu'une
assiette de frites avec une sauce
ketchup et
mayonnaise et on l'a mariné avec du sel
du thint et avec une sauce barbecue et
du
paprika pas mal moi je trouve que c'est
un menu plutôt pas mal c'est grave c'est
làù mélange ça ça ça ça c'est une vidéo
qui a circulé ça est-ce que vous vous
rendez compte moi je pense pas que ce
soit marginal moi je pense qu'il y a un
antisémitisme très très important dans
notre pays P on s' rend c'est très grave
très grave rendez compte qui marchait
sur le drapeau israélien je sais pas si
vous l'avez vu une vidéo pareil où elle
décrit son look et CETA et où elle dit
ah j'ai pas oublié Israël et elle a sous
la chaussure sous sa semelle le drapeau
israélienout là où les homes c'est là où
les hommes politiques et les médias ont
un ont un devoir c'est que ils sont en
train d'infuser ils sont en train
d'infuser de libérer une parole et comme
par hasard on a toute une série comme ça
de débiles mteaux qui basculent dans le
né ionisme ou dans l'antisémitisme et
c'est ça le problème ce dont on parle
avec guillaumis tu me parles tu me
parles de je suis char non tu peux pas
être Charlie lorsqu'il s'agit de
basculer dans quelque chose qui est
interdit ça tombe sous le coup de la loi
c'est du racisme pur et dur on ne peut
pas l'excuser parce que c'est un
humoriste ou un mec intelligent je m'en
fous tout ce qui se passe en ce moment
c'est que la France insoumise est en
train de libérer tout un tas de dingu la
parole il désinhible la parole vous avez
tout à fait raison et après on se
retrouve avec ces gensl
Laé n fr
TER cont
R